consternation est palpable à labé ou un
autre glissement de terrain menacent de
se produire par mesure préventive 53
familles ont dû quitter leur demeure
dans la nuit de samedi à dimanche
l'ordre d'évacuation pourrait durer
plusieurs mois
l'incubation peut loger chose à environ
deux heures on n'a pas de famille ici
ventre quand on va voir un
investissement mon fils est né là d'un
vaste maison le tout via j'ai pris un
bond de 3 bus promener je me stationne à
chaque pièce chaque somme toute
on n'est pas dans la rue schéma salle
il y avait
tout est mise en branle à 5 mai afin de
reloger plus de 180 sinistrés plusieurs
solutions sont envisagées et la
déclaration de l'état d'urgence
facilitera le travail alors ça ça va
donner la possibilité à des années et
dcm sujet rare le directeur de prendre
des décisions qui considérant que oui
c'est un état d'urgence malheureusement
mais heureusement tout le monde et a
envie on parle avec le feu d'habitation
depuis depuis le début alors il ya des
logements qui sont maintenant
disponibles ça ça rassure et beaucoup
d'espoir y ait une multitude de
solutions mais avant il faut connaître
besoin on ne tue des familles ont noté
des personnes âgées à mobilité réduite
donc c'est vraiment les besoins mais
tout est ouvert le du terrain de camping
en passant par la résidence de personnes
âgées par la résidence étudiante par la
famille ou des bons samaritains d'autres
expertises seront faites prochainement
pour analyser le sol les experts
estiment que sa composition ressemble à
celle de saint jean vianney ou un
glissement de terrain avait coûté la vie
à trente et une personnes en mai 1971
les autorités sont sur le qui vive alors
et tu l écoute c'est un risque de
mouvements sont imminents donc c'est
certain que tout pourrait se produire
mais notre priorité c'était d'évacuer le
pire est passé la ville continue son
travail pour tenter de limiter les
dégâts des digues sont installés pour
retenir un éventuel glissement ici
gabriel morissette radio canada saguenay